au problème de débouchés pour 7 juillet
jeunesse guyanaise s'ajoute aujourd'hui
le cas d'environ 20% des enfants issus
de pays frontaliers comme le surinam ou
le brésil des enfants qui sont peu
scolarisés est pratiquement à l'alphabet
tu marques maisons neuves à la poigne
8h30
un matin comme les autres pour ces
enfants là mais meurent dans la rue mais
pour eux il n'y a pas de place à l'école
lequel va pas à l'école
il ne parle que la langue locale le
takita qui comme 600 autres enfants qui
eux non plus n'ont pas de place en cours
savoir que depuis quelques années par
année ses 10 15 voire viennent de classe
où nous construisons chaque année
actuellement nous sommes arrivés au
point où n'auront plus les moyens de
construire ni même d'entretenir ce que
nous avons construit il ya quelques
années
johnny s'est réfugié en guyane avec sa
famille il vient du surinam en cinq ans
saint laurent du maroni est passé de
5000 à 15 mille habitants et même si la
moitié de la population est en âge
scolaire les crédits n'ont pas suivi mec
là j'ai dit pas quelle place encore plus
folle et qu'est ce qui fonde la journée
en guyane 20% de la population est
analphabète
dans cette école ces enfants sont
français même si pour la plupart leurs
parents viennent du surinam ou du guyana
en entrant en classe ils apprennent
qu'un français spécialement adaptée
avant les maths ou les sciences
naturelles
bon je suis parti d'un support j'irai un
local utilisé des méthodes qui a été
créée poursuit localement mais je
travaille aussi sur le catalogue
les premiers temps il n'y a pas que les
enfants qui ont fait un peu de mal à
s'adapter jusqu'en sixième
les enfants ne manquent jamais l'école
car ils savent qu'ici avoir une place et
un privilège